alors disque en 1997 photos osées une
bonne tête de vainqueur mais nous étions
dix premiers cas là j'attends tout pile
20 ans comme ça ya 20 ans la jeune des
frères table un total de dons du coma et
treize élèves dans les frères mais
attend c'est que celles perdues des
couloirs là bien c'est après ça que tu
as connu syndicats ont annoncé après
ouais bah comme quoi ça donne beaucoup
d'espoir à plein de gens mes frères et
moi tu connais pour stéphane bern avec
le foulard beige est passée la bonne
année fou génial et très bien eu
beaucoup plus beau cadeau cadeaux pour
vous j'ai 25 ans dont 95 g/km avec nous
oui absolument
je voudrais travailler avec nous
maintenant j'adore cette photo c'est
plein de cadeaux p 8 millions à beinheim
alors vous c'est quoi alors et ben moi
j'étais un concours de tajines jeu c'est
une photo je démarrais la télévision
donc elle doit dater de 97 ans
[Applaudissements]
voilà le pied bot le pied bondir à
moules ou un gardien sur manille ont
différé des pieds de boules ou non mais
sans rigoler c'est vrai elle est belle
et le mollet et magnifique à trimolet
vous avez une belle pomme et naïm
simiesque étonnant déchet c'était dans
une nouvelle demeure
[Rires]
c'est quand elle était enfant maintenant
la la même photo ma center parcs à
bétail de ma mère était mariée avec le
gars qui métier tout en dépassant encore
marié je croyais l'aide à waimes et et
avec lui la jeunesse en euros
j'étais avec lui de censure à nous et
pas toujours capables change et à la
même tête
ah oui il ya juste teillet qui ont
changé j'adore la france ils sont
mineurs sont encore plus beau elle a des
pieds benhaim opposons je reste dessus
vous le poussez qui ne vous effraie pas
du tout à la halle aux pieds on appelle
ça comment ça s'est passé la barre des
tips égyptien exactement d'andré gide
sien c'est quand le pousser un peu plus
long que est donc là c'est quoi c'est
vrai un drôle de pied dans le personnage
de big deal c'est ce que vous étiez tôt
possible c'est ce que je me tiens à lui
dire et de le faire tous les jours aux
médias incroyable une fois 30 ans a été
tuée frère tu fais ça tu vois tu te tais
les portes a fait ça ça t'as plus qu'un
père de saad
écoute moi je connais vous avez ramené
photo oublier sa 90 noir et blanc n'ont
alors plus jolie est fermée les jeudis
glace mais je dis la vérité
dakar 6 août aps été cent fois mieux
maintenant non mais c'est bien dans mon
irritation paris-dakar la mauritanie à
nouakchott
ah ouais je faisais quoi là-bas j'étais
reporter à françois je suivais le paris
dakar ce qu'on a du mal à croire qu'il
était reporter toiture c'est vrai
franchement franchement aujourd'hui
trace du dakar me dis pas que tu avais
la cote avec cette tête et non pas
spécialement et j'étais mariée puis
c'est pour ça qu'on se marre et comme ça
on est tranquille ok si les critères
étaient pas les mêmes dans les années 90
non mais franchement il ya personne avec
une faute des années 90 qui pourrait
séduire aujourd'hui au delormeau était
beau gosse je suis en train de
renégocier son contrat
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est vrai que jamais été moche et
rod a toujours été content on rigole ça
va notre ami la piscine qui lit à haute
voix
c'est qu'en ce moment je te dis
franchement tu es mon étoile vous devez
donc je dis tuer tuer tuer tuer ma
grande ourse
non mais je le dis je suis fou de toi
geronzi un débat va signer c'est j'ai un
peu de mal ça va tomber ou toi
sentimentalement d'ailleurs à joker non
pas la locale et parfois douce montant
est là latine elle veut faire non que
nous à la bafa veut faire des secrets à
la télé alors qu'un outre on n'a pas la
question il n'y en a pas une autre à
l'âme et inquiète par mais je sais que
toi oui toi je vais te bien inquiète pas
maintenant de photos ah oui mais j'étais
mama qui je suis et reste était mieux
maintenant c'est toujours la vérité
mais sa coiffure tout va beaucoup mieux
maintenant
ouais je me sens mieux maintenant
franche est vrai j'avais 20 ans 4 en
1990 je vais pas voir avec ça
comme elle l'a annoncé c'est bizarre
d'ailleurs plus fatigués à 20 ans
qu'aujourd'hui la région
[Applaudissements]
sur la taille ou ma mère est sur cette
photo frère on dirait que tu viens de
faire cinq heures deux mon frère tu n'as
pas ton niveau ça car je crois que
j'avais même pas encore embrassé un
garçon la fin tu avais encore embrassé
un garçon et non j'avais lalime a 20 ans
des jeunes à un dictionnaire comme ça
dit m non non mais là j'ai beaucoup de
cernes je suis né avec des cernes que je
cache ton chalandon je suis
naturellement avec plein de cernes et
tout le temps j'ai fait la fête
alors quand même à 20 ans j'avais la
main on attend magnifique et non mais
n'en fait pas elle va pas de péter tapas
pas du tout dans le même registre et
autant d'années le monde
[Applaudissements]
la touche attention doit sa peine quand
on est jeune on est bien foutu dehors
mon programme
oui vous où tu ne devrais pas vous
devriez bien je suis en beauce maribel à
oui c'est une photo
[Applaudissements]
borges poète georges moi j'en ai envoyé
deux une deux mois en 89 ou 90 je sais
plus je suis triste parce que je crois
que la france et oui 18,5 par un disque
[Applaudissements]
elle est aimée c'est parce est vrai
c'est pas elle et je n'avais mis notre
avec mon fils non mais je préfère ça
ah ouais et remettez l'autre parce que
away mais franchement vous êtes
magnifique oui j'en rigolais pas être
avoir été mais aussi belges je vous le
dis tous les jours et de délires
différents l'aca carré plongeant
là on a une autre coiffure ses coûts à
quel moment où commencent à pousser les
colliers parce que l'assemblée avait pas
à l'époque
c'est je crois que je sortais de là nous
aime et vous avez une épaule magnifique
quoi deux épaules de l'homme au maroc a
relevé 16 ans sur cette photo avec leurs
amis à l'époque les aimait bien mon pote
était lui on monte on descend il a pas
il a passé une partie des bois va partir
et nathan des worlds apart
non non non aimer et les nuages et
réunion avait déjà de belles poutres
[Rires]
elle est à ce que c'est non c'est une
blague
franchement ça c'est une blague mobilier
c'est pas une blague mobilières je ne
savais pas m'en servir
barack obama voit le jour à lancer au
kadima y est alors dans les années 90
xavier quel âge 22 ans 22 ans
alors faites quoi vous avez mis de
l'huile sur vos acolytes afin de tout
pas du beurre de lui vous allez faire
des tours elle a salué lundi alors
qu'ils étaient maintenant attendre le
zoo également j'étais à new york et la
photographe s'appelle caréna tyra tard
inatteignable et c'était un spécial 9
semaines et ça allait être un petit peu
a été exceptionnel cadre qu'est ce
qu'elle est belle
merci aller à l'analyse de l'économie
auquel on estime non mais elle est jetée
mannequin pour payer mais c'est là qu'il
m'a dit tu es magnifique aujourd'hui
vraiment le cas pour payer tessiture et
maintenant tu fais quoi pour payer ses
études
je les touche pas à mon poste ah bah non
tu vois pas beaucoup de gens le
comprennent à l'arrivée ça va ça veut
dire pour lui parce que je veux pas
passer d'un combat sans annuler
non non non il ya toujours été bonnes
non non on va peut pas dire on va voir
[Applaudissements]
cette photo el hout et exciter la manade
mais moi aussi j'adore quoi c'est pas
vrai mais aussi jeux steam pour le voc
breton compte google
les équipes ont bossé mais arrêter avec
cette surprise à chaque fois que vous
vous trouvez pas trop j'avais 20 ans et
je vous dis la vérité je vais partir en
vacances avec mon meilleur pote
sébastien sera qui je bosse encore et
adore le dernier jour des vacances on
s'est dit on n'a fait aucune photo donc
on a fait en 2 heures toutes les photos
dr et a plaidé pour des pauses comme ça
faussement naturel les gens sont là dès
l'époque de top gun riche histoire
j'adore quand on voit les côtes comme ça
elle va chez le boucher
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
magnifique dans les années 90 avec elles
à 28 ans 87 donc cette photo normalement
j'avais six ans le club dorothée les
mini comme et même en 93 1 mais le mec
il déroule sa bio je chéris 1,93 à la
berline mais dans l'ailé alors c'est le
bambin toute une génération a été touché
par cette série à ce concept à la coupe
un peu de 10° dylan marois
complémentaires on était potes
ouais
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'avais une fois ça suffit c'est tout on
n'a pas d'autre et salah est folle la
première s'il vous plaît pas au niveau
où vous n'avez pas changé du tout mais
c'est vrai mais oui même sans rigoler
c'est la même racine et ouais ouais
c'est vrai mais t'es mignon la roma ça
va j'avais mon petit succès la
d'artagnan tunisois